fast drei Monate Krieg in der Ukraine
putinskrieg geht im Osten des Landes
weiter und wir wollen einen weiteren
Blick werfen auf die militärische Lage
wir sehen uns einmal erstmal die
Situation an über die wir gerade
sprechen und wir müssen uns heute
Material angucken aus der Region Raki 4
oben wo die ukrainische gegen Offensive
relativ gut läuft aber auch aus der
Region du hansk wo weiterhin russische
Truppen vordringen und russische Truppen
auch weiteren Städte erobern
als allererstes Aufnahmen die ja auch
für uns ganz neu sind hier gemacht von
einer russischen Überwachungsdrohne und
wir sehen da oben diesen Stern in der
Ecke das ist Silvester Fernsehen also
Stern Fernsehen oder das Fernsehen eben
der russischen Armee das russische
militärfernsehen wir sehen hier
Aufnahmen die gemacht wurden und eben
auch übertragen wurden von und das ist
ganz spannend amerikanischer schwerer
Artillerie das ist die sogenannte m77
die haben schon einige Male vorgestellt
davon hat die USA der Ukraine insgesamt
90 Stück versprochen 79 sollen davon ein
bisschen lang angekommen sein und diese
Artilleriegeschütze sind ja zum einen
eine große Angst natürlich für Putin
weil sie 40 Kilometer weit sehr genau
schießen können auf der anderen Seite
aber eben auch ein absolutes ja
wichtiges Ziel für die russische
Luftwaffe und für die russischen
Einheiten und wir lassen es mal ganz
kurz laufen und sehen uns mal an wie
Russland die hier angreift denn was wir
jetzt sehen ist hier eine Explosion die
stattfindet und das müssen wir uns noch
mal einmal genauer ansehen was nämlich
ziemlich einmalig
ein bisschen was wir gucken uns gleich
mal hier an wir ganz links auf der Seite
wenn man das mal sehen kann hier sehen
wir was da auf die
Artillerie zufliegt und das ist eine
Kamikaze Drohne der russischen Armee
eine sogenannte zalakup die hier
eingesetzt wird und wir Zoomen ein
bisschen raus und gucken uns das Ganze
an diese Saaler Kopf liegt also weiter
wir sehen jetzt wie sie hier ist
mittlerweile noch mal kurz um das zu
zeigen wie sie hier ist und wir sehen
dann wie sie immer weiter auf die
Artillerie zufliegt das ist jetzt kurz
vor dem Einschlag hier ist sie wir
gucken das zu Ende an und sehen die
Explosion die hier stattfindet wir sehen
die ukrainischen Soldaten die gerade
noch so wegrennen können und
glücklicherweise für die ukana findet
hier keine Explosion erstmal statt aber
wir haben weitere drohnenaufnahmen
dieser ukrainische Konvoi wird offenbar
gejagt von der russischen Luftwaffe denn
er hat diese m 777 Artilleriegeschütze
sie er versteckt sich jetzt hier in
einem Wald wir sehen wie die Russen das
ganz genau beobachten die wissen genau
wo die Ukrainer sind zum Glück für die
Ukrainer
können sie nicht so genau zielen und
haben nicht so genaue Waffen um das um
sozusagen die Vernichtung anzustreben
die Sie gern wollen wir haben eben
gesehen die Drohne hat etwa um 10 Meter
verfehlt ihr Ziel jetzt sehen wir ein
mehrfach raketenwerferangriff überall
Explosion und wir wissen die Ukrainer
verstecken sich hier im Wald wo wir sie
eben gesehen haben dort glücklicherweise
für sie gibt es erstmal keine Explosion
allerdings rum herum mit anderen Worten
diese amerikanischen Artilleriegeschütze
die wirklich sehr genau sind und sehr
tödlich sind das absolute ja man sagt
Prime target sozusagen für die russische
Armee die die Jagd und die den immer
weiter hinterher fährt wir gucken uns
mal an noch eine neue Stadt die erobert
wurde von Russland die wie Russland sagt
befreit wurde und sehen uns einmal mehr
an was Befreiung denn hier bedeutet das
ist die Stadt rubischen jemals 21.000
Einwohner in der Region luhanski ist
etwas seit einer Woche unter russischer
Kontrolle und wir sehen hier völlige
Zerstörung kein einziger Mensch lebt
dort mehr auch hier wurde jeder Mensch
vertrieben die steht die Kämpfe haben
die ganze Stadt zerstört die Russen
sehen Sie jetzt in Anführungsstrichen
befreit und wir sehen Ukrainer oder auch
irgendwelche andere Menschen gibt es da
nicht mehr nur noch russische Soldaten
die sozusagen ihr eigenes Werk das Werk
ihrer Vernichtung hier Filmen und ja das
offenbar weiterhin als eine Art
Befreiung verkaufen wollen
das in der Region nur Hans wo weiterhin
schauen uns das mal an wo weiterhin ein
russischer Vorstoß stattfindet gerade
die Stadt severuskie ist extrem wichtig
für die Russen wir haben eben
europäische gesehen ganz in der Nähe
auch die Stadt Liman hier ist weiterhin
umkämpft und wahrscheinlich mit bereits
komplett von den Russen eingenommen ein
anderes Bild ergibt sich in der Region
Haki 4 im Norden da haben wir in den
letzten Tagen schon immer wieder gesagt
da gab es einen ukrainischen
Gegenangriff der eben die Stadt aus dem
Würgegriff von Putins Schagen auch von
Putins Artillerie und Raketen dort
befreit hat und dort die Russen immer
weiter zurückgedrängt hat Richtung
Grenze wir sehen auch nur dann ganz
dünner Streifen hier oben und wie machen
die Ukrainer das das machen sie mit den
westlichen Waffen auch wieder westliche
Waffen in diesem mal in
Anführungsstrichen unterwegs sind alte
sowjetische Panzer die da geliefert
wurden und zwar von Polen wir sehen es
hier das sind T-72 Panzer t72mpanzer aus
Polen von denen Polen wahrscheinlich bis
zu 100 an die Ukraine geliefert hat in
den letzten in den letzten Wochen diese
Panzer wurden nochmal aufgerüstet wir
sehen hier diese Verstärkung auf beiden
Seiten das ist sogenannte ära1
reaktiv Panzerung die also noch ein
bisschen ein bisschen dicker ist ein
bisschen mehr dafür sorgen soll dass
wenn der Panzer getroffen wird von etwas
dass es nicht direkt die Hülle trifft
sondern erstmal diese sogenannten bricks
also diese Ziegelsteine außen rum trifft
wir sehen aber dass diese Panzer hier in
großer Zahl vorrücken und zwar östlich
von krativ und nördlich von krativ das
sind die neuen ukrainischen Panzer wenn
man so will und insofern ist auch dieses
Argument was immer wieder genannt wird
ja ja diese alten sowjetischen Sachen
die bringen der Ukraine ja gar nichts
das ist völlig hinfällig die auch keiner
kann daraus moderne oder sozusagen
zumindest nutzbare Waffen machen mit
denen sie eben weiter vorrücken können
in der Region was Sie brauchen sind
weitere schwere weitere Waffen mit denen
sie eben den russischen Vormarsch
zurückdrängen können wir haben es eben
gesehen sie haben einige
Artilleriegeschütze auch von den USA
erhalten das reicht noch lange nicht was
sie bräuchten wer beispielsweise die
deutsche Panzerhaubitze 2000 denn anders
als diese m 777 die wir eben gesehen
haben wir gucken uns das nochmal an zu
Abschluss die eben sehr langsam sich
bewegt die aufgebaut werden muss die
lange an einem Ort ist und deshalb eben
zum Ziel dieser Kamikaze drohen wird ist
es mit der Panzerung bis zu 2000 ganz
anders die kann irgendwo hinfahren
direkt aus der Bewegung quasi nur kurz
stehen bleiben schießen innerhalb von 12
Minuten und dann wieder wegfahren das
ist was ganz anderes als diese Haubitzen
hier die eben gezogen werden die sich
verstecken müssen im Wald die nicht
einfach so flüchten können insofern wäre
diese ja von Deutschland angeblich bald
gelieferte Panzerhaubitze 2007 Stück für
Deutschland davon liefern wer etwas sehr
Wichtiges für die ukrainische Armee um
eben im Osten des Landes weiter Boden
gut zu machen